so if we actually return back to Poker
and chess are some of the ideas that
you're learning here with diplomacy
could you construct AI systems that play
like humans
like um
make for a fun opponent
in a game with Jess yeah absolutely
we've already started looking into this
direction a bit so we tried to use the
techniques that we've developed for
diplomacy uh to make chess and go AIS
and what we found is that it led to much
more human-like strong chess and go
players
the way that
AIS like stockfish today play is in a
very inhuman style it's very strong but
it's very different from how humans play
and so we can take the techniques that
we've developed for diplomacy we do
something similar in um in chess and go
and we end up with the bot that's both
strong and human-like
um to elaborate on this a bit like one
way to approach making a human-like AI
for chess is to collect a bunch of human
games like a bunch of human Grand Master
games and just do supervised learning on
those games but the problem is that if
you do that what you end up with is an
AI That's substantially weaker than the
human Grand Masters that you've trained
on because the neural net is not able to
approximate the the Nuance of the
strategy this goes back to the planning
thing that I mentioned the search thing
that I talked about before that these
human Grand Masters when they're playing
they're using search and they're using
planning and the neural net alone unless
you have a massive neural net that's
like a thousand times bigger than what
we have right now it's not able to
approximate those details very
effectively
and on the other hand you can leverage
search and planning very heavily but
then what you end up with is an AI that
plays in a very different style from how
humans play the game
now if you strike this intermediate
balance by setting the um the
regularization parameters correctly and
say you can do planning but try to keep
it close to the human policy then you
end up with an AI that plays in both a
very human-like style and a very strong
style and you can actually even tune it
to have a certain ELO rating so you can
say play in the style of like a 2800
elohiman
um I wonder if you could do specific
type of humans or categories of humans
so not just skill but Style
yeah I think so and so this is this is
where the the research gets interesting
like you know one of the things that I
was thinking about is and this is
actually already being done I think
there's a researcher at the University
of Toronto that's working on this
um is to make an ad that plays in the
style of a particular player like Magnus
Carlson for example you can make an AI
that plays like Magnus Carlson and then
where I think this gets interesting is
like maybe you're up against Magnus
Carlson in the world championship or
something you can play against this
Magnus Carlson bot to prepare against
the real Magnus Carlson and you can try
to explore strategies that he might
struggle with
um and try to figure out like how do you
beat this player in particular
um on the other hand you can also have
Magnus Carlson working with this bot to
try to figure out where he's weak
um and where he needs to improve his
strategy
um and so I can Envision this future
where data on specific chess and go
players becomes extremely valuable
because you can use that data to create
specific models of how these particular
players play so increasingly human-like
behavior and Bots however
as you've mentioned makes cheating cheat
detection much harder it it does yeah
the way that sheet detection Works in a
game like poker and a game like chess
and go from what I understand is trying
to see like is this person making moves
that are very common among chess AIS or
you know AIS in general
um but very uncommon among top human
players
and if you have the development of these
AIS that play in a very strong style but
also a very human-like style then that
poses serious challenges for cheat
detection and it makes you now ask
yourself a hard question about what is
the role of AI systems as they become
more and more integrated in our society
and this kind of human AI
um integration has has some deep ethical
issues that we should be aware of and
also it's a kind of cyber security
challenge right for to make you know one
of the assumptions we have when we play
games is that there's a trust that is
only humans involved
and there
the better AI systems to create which
makes it super exciting human-like AI
systems with different styles of humans
is really exciting but then we have to
have the defenses better and better and
better if we're to trust that we uh can
enjoy human versus human game in a
deeply Fair way it's fascinating so it's
just uh it's humbling yeah I think there
is a lot of like negative potential for
this kind of Technology but you know at
the same time there's a lot of upside
for it as well so you know for example
right now it's really hard to learn how
to get better in games like chess and
poker and go because the way that the AI
plays is so foreign and incomprehensible
yeah but if you have these AIS that are
playing you know you can say like Oh I'm
a 2000 ELO human how do I get to 2200
now you can have an AI that plays in the
style of a 2200 ELO human and that will
help you get better or you know you
mentioned this problem of like how do
you know that you're actually playing
with humans when you're playing like
online in video games well now we have
the potential of populating these like
Virtual Worlds with
um agents like AI agents that are
actually fun to play with and you don't
have to always be playing with other
humans to to you know have a fun time
so yeah a lot a lot of upside potential
too and I think you know with any sort
of tool there's there's the potential
for a lot of greatness and a lot of uh
downsides as well